The One Piece manga finally answered one of
THE BIGGEST AND MOST IMPORTANT questions of
this recent flashback by showing us that Jewelry
Bonney is indeed the daughter of the Revolutionary
Ginny.
But while we finally had that relationship
confirmed now we have WAY MORE questions than
we started with.
Because in this chapter we were told that
Ginny was apparently kidnapped and forced
to become the wife of a world noble.
So maybe she was sold by slavers or something.
But wow, out of all the options we discussed
for Bonney’s father like Kuma or Dragon,
Oda chose THE DARKEST WAY that this backstory
could go.
I mean yeah, we’ve always known that Celestial
Dragons can just randomly pick people and
force them to become their wives, like we
saw in chapter 499.
But man, seeing it like this and that Bonney
is the child of this forced marriage is a
whole different level of messed up.
Oda is seriously ramping up the tragic meter
to a whole other level.
But to make things even worse for Ginny, we
next see her two years later and she has somehow
been struck by a deadly disease.
Unfortunately, instead of getting help she
is kicked out of Mary Geoise and left alone
to die.
Which is where we see her next in one of THE
MOST heartbreaking moments in recent one piece.
Because with her dying breaths Ginny calls
Kuma and tells him once again that she loves
him.
And man, I won’t lie and say that I didn’t
tear up a bit when I saw that.
I don’t think Oda has ever done a better
job of making me so emotionally invested in
two characters in a flashback.
I mean Ginny and Kuma’s story is up there
with Law and Corazon for me.
They’ve been through slavery, poverty, pain,
hunger, and years spent together as kids and
later as revolutionaries.
Which makes it even more tragic when Kuma
is eventually able to identify where Ginny
is and he instantly pushes himself there using
his devil fruit, but what he finds is honestly
just so tragic.
Ginny is dead, with a baby Bonney in her arms.
I mean, whew…
I don’t know guys…
This one hit me HARD.
Oda has built up Kuma as this impossibly kind
and compassionate figure and now he’s had
one of the only people who he truly cared
for ripped away.
It’s truly heartbreaking, and just continues
to make me hate the celestial dragons more
and more.
What’s interesting though is that this scene
seems to confirm Bonney’s age to be around
twelve years old since this happened about
twelve years ago.
Which has crazy implications for the present
story, but before we move on from Ginny I
want to quickly speculate on who this might
this evil person that Ginny was forced to
marry might be.
And I have one crazy theory that is just incredibly
twisted.
Listen to this.
We don’t get much evidence on who Bonney’s
father is from the chapter, but let’s go
back again to chapter 499.
This is the first chapter we ever meet this
world noble, Saint Charlos, and this entire
scene might actually be some INSANE foreshadowing.
Because as soon as Charlos is introduced,
he kicks an injured man and then decides to
take this random nurse as his wife.
This woman, by the way, was already engaged
to be married, which is kinda similar to the
Ginny and Kuma situation.
But what’s most interesting is what happens
next.
Because then Zoro shows up and nearly causes
massive chaos by cutting down Charlos.
Fortunately for Zoro though Bonney steps in
and uses her powers to get him out of trouble.
And now I’m just sitting here wondering
if Oda intentionally showed us Bonney’s
powers FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME in the EXACT
SAME CHAPTER where a world noble kidnapped
a woman to make them their wife.
I mean, wow, seriously how insane is it that
and almost exactly six hundred chapters later,
we are shown the very same thing happened
to Bonney’s own mother.
So as much as it hurts me to say this, this
may have been some twisted foreshadowing about
Bonney’s actual father.
Because if we take this scene in chapter 499
as foreshadowing then wouldn’t it make sense
that Bonney’s mother was married to Charlos’
father, who is Saint Roswald, whom we met
just a few chapters before this scene?
And to make even more connections, in chapter
497 Roswald killed a slave who also had his
own wife and child, which yeah is kinda a
loose connection to Ginny and Bonney, but
I’m just saying that having all this all
occur so close together could have been hinting
at Bonney’s father all along.
But if you want a more concrete bit of evidence
just look at chapter 908, when we see Bonney
sneaking into Mary Geoise.
In this same scene, Kuma is shown being ridden
by who else, but Saint Roswald.
Which could all just be some sort of horribly
tragic joke that Ginny was forced to marry
the man who later rode Kuma around like a
horse.
Man, if this is all true, then Oda has gone
to a whole other level of twisted in this
backstory.
And if Roswald is Bonney’s father, then
that actually means Bonney is related to Charlos
and his sister.
Which is just, uhh.
Terrible.
Awful.
I don’t want that thought in my brain.
However, it is entirely possible that Ginny
was married to some other random World Noble
that we’ve never heard of.
Or if we want to name other important nobles
perhaps someone like Garling, which would
somehow mean that Bonney and Shanks are related,
possibly either as siblings or cousins.
Taking it one step further, what if it was
even one of the Gorosei.
I mean we’ve never seen them with children
or wives or anything like that, but maybe
that is why Bonney is just bursting with tears
when fighting Saturn at the end of chapter
1094.
Surely these tears we see in this panel have
to mean Bonney is feeling some sort of deeper
feelings than just hatred for Saturn.
Obviously, it is suggested that Saturn is
the one who ordered Kuma’s memories erased,
but what if it is more than that and Saturn
is the one who forced Ginny to marry him?
In fact, one theory from WorstGenHQ on twitter
suggests that maybe Saturn was the one who
caused Ginny’s deadly disease in the first
place.
Maybe somehow it was a side effect of Saturn’s
demon-like abilities that made Ginny and Bonney
sick in the first place.
And if that is true, then if Bonney is somehow
able to kill Saturn by the end of this arc
it would certainly be fitting justice.
And while this is all getting a bit too dark
for my tastes, if any of these options are
true, and Oda’s not just hiding her real
father somehow, then that means that Bonney
actually has Celestial Dragon blood in her
veins.
Which just makes me incredibly curious why
they would throw her out with her mother without
even trying to save her.
I mean, Ginny wasn’t a Celestial Dragon,
so that makes sense that they wouldn’t care
about her dying, but Bonney being at least
half-blood has to mean something, right?
Could this play some role later on in the
conflict between Bonney and Saturn?
Although, honestly it seems like the demon
Saturn is showing absolutely no hesitation
in trying to kill Bonney, so either he doesn’t
care about her lineage or she doesn’t actually
have noble blood in the first place.
Or to throw just one more crazy idea out there,
what if Oda is still faking use out and Bonney
still isn’t Ginny’s daughter?
And sure, call me crazy, but we’ve been
wrong about assumptions like this in the past,
so I’m not ruling it out just yet.
In fact, I also still think the clone option
is still on the table and could explain how
Bonney is alive, but more on that in just
a minute.
And while her father’s identity remains
a mystery, I’m also highly interested in
figuring out this strange disease that affected
Bonney and her mother.
It is called Sapphire Scale, and it is even
rarer than the Amber Lead disease that wiped
out Law’s entire town during his flashback.
And what we know about this disease is that
when people who have the disease go out in
the sun or moon light, their entire body starts
to turn blue and their skin becomes hard,
like rock or some sort of tough animal scales.
Now, we aren’t told how she got this disease
or if it is contagious, but if it is anything
like the Amber Lead disease, then it might
be caused by something horrible that the world
nobles were doing.
If you remember from Law’s flashback, Law’s
hometown would mine this Amber Ore which was
actually deathly poisonous over time and could
be passed down through generations.
Which seems to also have happened in this
case since Bonney also has the disease.
And I honestly have no idea what could have
caused it other than maybe some government
experimentation or maybe a side-effect of
one of the Gorosei’s demon powers or something.
But this leaves us with the question of how
did Bonney live while her mother died?
And the answer to this question is going to
have a HUGE effect on the rest of Kuma and
Bonney’s story.
Because we see in this chapter that Kuma took
care of Bonney for quite a long time.
To protect her from the disease he kept her
out of the sunlight for YEARS.
Can you just imagine that?
Literally not being able to go outside.
I know Kuma would bring her books and everything,
and we even finally learned the heart-breaking
origin of his famous last question: “If
you could travel anywhere, where would you
like to go?”
Now though we get some more of the most wholesome
panels in the entire story as we see a young
Bonney growing up with Kuma.
And man while reading this I just couldn’t
help but wish that Kuma had agreed to marry
Ginny all those years ago.
Then they could have actually lived together
as a happy family.
But man, I guess it was never meant to be.
And even though we see these two spending
the years together, we just always knew this
was going to end in some sort of tragedy.
But sadly they couldn’t live like this forever
because a doctor told Kuma that the disease
would still kill her by the time she was ten
years old.
So how was she cured?
Well, one option is that Kuma used his Paw
devil fruit to somehow push the disease out
of Bonney.
Which sounds crazy, but we’ve been seeing
Kuma push out things like pain, so it isn’t
unreasonable to think the Kuma could push
this disease.
However, like we just saw in chapter 1097,
someone would have to take in that disease
which means that Kuma might have absorbed
the disease himself to save Bonney.
Now whether he was just strong enough to survive
the disease or it didn’t affect him because
of his Buccaneer blood, we aren’t really
sure.
But if you look at this small flashback in
chapter 1072, it does appear Kuma has some
bandages on his entire body, so I wonder if
this could be some sort of side-effect from
this Sapphire Scale disease.
Of course, another option for how Bonney lived
is that Kuma made some sort of deal with the
world nobles to save Bonney.
And the easiest way for this to work would
be that Kuma basically sold himself to the
world nobles in exchange for medicine or possibly
even Bonney’s age devil fruit.
I mean, since the disease is indeed age-related
then Bonney’s fruit would be the perfect
one to keep her from ever growing too old
too be killed.
Although she definitely has aged herself up
past ten years old, which makes me wonder
if that is true or not.
Maybe that leaves open the option that the
real Bonney did die and the one we see now
is a clone??
I don’t know honestly, I’m still trying
to wrap my head around all of this
But whatever the case, Bonney is alive, and
she is now confirmed to only be twelve years
old.
Which is just crazy to think that she’s
already gone around and become a famous pirate
while still basically a child, but maybe her
devil fruit’s powers also affect her brain
to match the age of her physical body.
And it appears that in the next chapter we
are finally going to see Kuma earn his title
of the Tyrant King of Sorbet kingdom.
Because at the end of this one, the corrupt
king that the freedom fighter overthrew in
chapter 1097 is back to cause trouble for
Sorbet Kingdom.
And honestly I thought he had been killed
already, which I wish was true, because now
I am predicting that someone is probably going
to try to take Bonney from Kuma, and man,
that is not going to end well.
I can just imagine Kuma destroying the ENTIRE
KINGDOM to try to save Bonney from being captured.
On the other hand, maybe the corrupt king
takes everyone on the island hostage and Kuma
is forced to trade himself to set them free.
It would make sense because Kuma has consistently
sacrificed himself to protect these people
over the years, so maybe he will take the
one option that sacrifices himself and saves
everyone else.
Or one more option to consider is that BOTH
Bonney and Kuma get taken in by the world
government.
Perhaps Kuma turns himself in to save the
people of Sorbet kingdom and then Bonney comes
along as well.
And this actually makes more sense than you
might think because we still have this unexplained
panel of former admiral Akainu saying he was
worried when he learned that she escaped.
And it doesn’t seem likely to me that he
was referring to when she was a literal baby,
so there has to be some other time that she
was captured and then escaped from the world
nobles.
On top of that, if you look at Bonney and
Kizaru’s conversation from chapter 1092
it does seem like Kizaru and Bonney have known
each other for quite some time as well.
Kizaru even remarks that she’s grown quite
a bit taller, which makes me think he saw
her some time when she was a kid.
So with all of this, I’m really thinking
that Bonney was with Kuma for at least the
start of when Kuma agreed to become a government
experiment and then she later escaped.
However, one thing that is certain is that
Bonney and Kuma’s backstory is going right
up there with the saddest in the entire story.
And if you know one thing about sad backstories,
it is that every single straw hat has one.
So there has never been a greater chance than
now for Bonney to join the crew.
But if you don’t want to wait to see exactly
how Bonney would work on a crew with Luffy,
I figured out how the entire Worst Generation
would get along on one crew, and you can check
out that video right here.
And I think we all probably saw the message
that Oda wasn’t able to finish the drawings
for this chapter.
So let’s all spare a prayer or some positive
thoughts that he is doing okay.
He works super hard every week to bring us
this story that we love, and nothing could
be worse than him overworking himself and
ruining his health.
Personally, I think it might be time to shift
to One Piece being every other week so he
has more time to rest.
But anyways, Shanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.